as a Jew we weren't told what the
questions Barry was my dad would even
say the word Christmas because it
contained the word Christ in it
for real he literally pronounced
Christmas drop schmear
[Music]
podcast called the skeptic tank please
give it up for mr. Ari Shaffir everybody
[Applause]
okay what do you guys think people like
saying better you think people that
saying Merry Christmas better or Happy
Hanukkah overwhelming Christmas huh
anti-semites all right fair
enough yeah I think it's Christmas too I
was in New York this year is my first
time being in New York for Christmas
I've always been in LA for like the
Christmas season which is the best time
of the year here because everyone leaves
so this place isn't like 30% capacity
you can find parking spots
it's wonderful like oh this is
how the city was built for this amount
of people it's great but I was in New
York and in New York they doll up the
streets they put like Christmas lights
all over and for the first time my life
I got the Christmas spirit
yeah I'd never gotten it before as a Jew
we weren't told what the Christmas
spirit was my dad wouldn't even say the
word Christmas because it contained the
word Christ in it for real he literally
pronounced Christmas Krosh Mir yeah he
wouldn't say with any sort of spite he
was just like I'm not saying that
word so what are you guys doing
for your crawfish me a break
and uh and so I never got the Christmas
beer before and listen you guys
Christians you've done a lot of
shady over the years but Christmas
spirit I've got no problem at all with
that that's just nice it's when you hold
the door open for somebody and go Merry
Christmas and you let they go in they go
Merry Christmas to you in the first year
in New York for the first time I got the
Christmas spirit I would hold it over
for everybody all the time
I'd like Merry Christmas they look at me
like are you sure cuz like I'm not
mocking you and like all right I'll go
in dear hold door open anyway so my
first year I got the Christmas spirit
and this year was one of those years
where Hanukkah and Christmas overlapped
was like Christmas felt like the fourth
day of Hanukkah and this was like three
or four days the first night of Hanukkah
I was walking down my my block in New
York and I passed some guy in the street
and he goes hey can I use your cell
phone it's like some Persian or Armenian
guy or something she's got nothing to do
with the story I don't know why it's
straight racism there's no reason to say
that at all there's nothing to do with
it anyway
and he goes can I use your cell phone
and you don't want a stranger asked to
use your cell phone that means that's a
guy who's about to steal your cell phone
yeah like sure guy with brand new Nikes
on I'm sure I'll give this to you but I
have a flip phone so I'm like yeah I'll
call your bluff you know what are you
gonna risk jail and run away for a
$19 piece of equipment you know
how to use so I was like here you go and
so he goes he opened it look how do you
honey
but it goes it over time I get mad it's
great and so he dialed and he goes uh he
dials him number and he goes hey it's a
delivery guy I'm downstairs I got your
food get a bag of food on him who's the
delivery guy I was like oh cool
and they handed me back the phone he
goes thanks I was like hey man Merry
Christmas
and he goes merry Christmas to you felt
great I felt like Martin Luther King jr.
I don't wanna go too far about that
level and then uh and then I walked away
feeling great about myself did a good
deed for the year and uh and then I got
about three to three blocks away and my
phone rang and uh it was the same number
I guess that that guy call it was coming
back I was like hello and he goes in the
new guy and goes uh where are you and I
didn't want to get involved you know so
I was just like I'm right downstairs and
he goes where I don't see you I'm like
I'm right here man and he's like what do
you look like I'm like I don't know I'm
like Persian or Armenian or something
I've got maybe a hoodie or a jacket I
forget now and he goes well I'm
downstairs I don't see anybody like that
I was like all right well I told Mike
listen man I'm not the guy and he's like
what what do you mean I'm like I'm not
the delivery guy he was like I just
talked to you and I'm like meet it and
you talk to something with a Persian or
Romanian accent for sure it was not me
it was I gave my phone to the delivery
guy he didn't have a cell phone I don't
know if you do familiar with the works
of Martin Luther King jr. but uh I'm a
lot like him and I let the guy use my
cell phone and then he called you and
the guy couldn't wrap his head around
he's like what wait what it's like
where's my food I'm like it's right
downstairs on 12th and B there's a guy
standing out there with a bag of what I
believe is your sandwich and he goes
well I'm on 13th and B I'm like oh well
you are one block away from your food
and he goes what do you want me to do
I'm like I don't care what you do really
but if you want your food I would say
start walking the twelfth and be just
there waiting for you and the guy who
has it has no cell phones so he's not
today on the contact - and he's like he
was like real indignities like well I'm
not paying for this I'm like yeah as an
American I don't think you should
there's something Mac still mad at me
like I had something to do with it I'm
not I'm just a good person he goes what
can you go tell him like nah
I'm like three blocks away you're one
block away you're way closer and if you
find them you get a sandwich out of it I
don't get anything out of them I find
them and then uh an even said it's
ridiculous and like yeah sure it is and
then he made a series of noises so next
30 or 40 seconds just like I mean just a
sound of white injustice you know it's
like we don't accept your expired coupon
Papa John's will take it I don't think
so but alright and then there was
nothing else to say you know there was
nothing else to do so eventually I just
told I was like okay well I was like I'm
gonna have the phone now and he goes
yeah I bet and I'm like well Happy
Hanukkah and he goes you
and then he hung up and that's how I
know people like saying Merry Christmas
better than Happy Hanukkah
[Music]
you